- أهلاً بكم في فهم
المعلومات الكمومية والحوسبة.
اسمي John Watrous، وأنا المدير التقني
لقسم التعليم في IBM Quantum.
الهدف من هذه السلسلة هو تزويدكم
بفهم متين للمعلومات الكمومية والحوسبة، وهذا يعني الدخول
في التفاصيل التقنية
للمعلومات الكمومية ورؤية كيف تعمل الحوسبة
الكمومية فعلاً، ما الذي يمكنها فعله وما الذي لا يمكنها فعله.
إذا لم تكونوا قد شاهدتم
فيديو النظرة العامة لهذه السلسلة بعد، أنصحكم بمشاهدته.
في ذلك الفيديو، ستجدون معلومات عن نوع الخلفية
المُوصى بها لهذه السلسلة، بالإضافة إلى مخطط
للمواضيع التي سيتم تغطيتها.
أيضاً، تأكدوا من الاطلاع
على كتاب Qiskit التعليمي، الذي يغطي نفس
المادة كهذه السلسلة المرئية بشكل مكتوب،
ويتضمن أيضاً
مكونات تفاعلية وواجهات للأجهزة والبرمجيات مصممة لمساعدتكم على فهم أفضل
للمعلومات الكمومية والحوسبة. ستجدون روابط لفيديو النظرة العامة وكتاب Qiskit التعليمي
في الوصف.
هذا هو الدرس الأول من
الوحدة الأولى في السلسلة.
الوحدة الأولى تغطي أساسيات
المعلومات الكمومية، وفي الدرس الأول من هذه الوحدة، سنركز على كيفية
عمل المعلومات الكمومية
للأنظمة المفردة، بمعنى أن لدينا
نظاماً فيزيائياً واحداً فقط أو جهازاً من نوع ما
يخزن المعلومات الكمومية
ونحن نعتبر كيف يعمل ذلك
النظام أو الجهاز الواحد بمعزل عن غيره.
في الدرس الذي يلي هذا، سنناقش كيف
تعمل المعلومات الكمومية عندما يكون لدينا أنظمة متعددة وهذا سيسمح لنا
بوصف مفاهيم مثيرة
ومهمة مثل الخوارزميات الكمومية التي تستخدم عدة qubits
وبروتوكولات كمومية
تشمل عدة أفراد يعالجون المعلومات الكمومية ويرسلونها ذهاباً
وإياباً لبعضهم البعض.
لكن قبل الدخول في تلك النقاشات، من المنطقي أن نبدأ بالإطار
البسيط نسبياً لنظام واحد بمعزل عن غيره،
جزئياً لأنه من الجيد البدء ببساطة، ولكن أيضاً لأننا كما سنرى، فإن وصف كيف
تعمل المعلومات الكمومية
للأنظمة المفردة بمعزل عن غيرها يقود بشكل طبيعي ومنطقي جداً إلى وصف كيف
للأنظمة المتعددة.
إليكم نظرة عامة موجزة على الدرس.
سنبدأ بمناقشة
المعلومات الكلاسيكية.
الآن، الهدف من هذا الدرس ليس شرح كيف
تعمل المعلومات الكلاسيكية، بل شرح كيف
تعمل المعلومات الكمومية،
لكن لشرح كيف
تعمل المعلومات الكمومية، من المفيد جداً البدء
بالمعلومات الكلاسيكية واستخدامها كنقطة
مرجعية مألوفة
عندما نناقش المعلومات الكمومية.
على المستوى الرياضي، المعلومات الكمومية والكلاسيكية لديها في الواقع أوصاف متشابهة جداً مع بعض الاختلافات الجوهرية بالطبع.
في الحقيقة، المعلومات الكمومية
ليست منفصلة عن المعلومات الكلاسيكية على الإطلاق.
إنها امتداد
للمعلومات الكلاسيكية.
الحقيقة هي،
على الأقل من وجهة نظري، أنه لا يمكنكم حقاً
فهم المعلومات الكمومية إذا لم تفهموا
المعلومات الكلاسيكية،
لذا البدء بالمعلومات
الكلاسيكية أمر منطقي.
أتوقع أن هذا
المحتوى سيكون مألوفاً لبعض المشاهدين، لكن حتى لو كنتم على دراية به، لا أنصحكم بتخطيه.
بالإضافة إلى تسليط الضوء على جوانب المعلومات الكلاسيكية الأكثر صلة
بفهم المعلومات الكمومية، سنقدم
ترميز Dirac في هذا الجزء،
وهو طريقة قياسية
سنستخدمها لوصف المتجهات
والمصفوفات طوال السلسلة.
كما اتضح، ترميز Dirac ليس
خاصاً بالمعلومات الكمومية.
يمكن استخدامه بنفس الكفاءة في سياق المعلومات الكلاسيكية وكذلك في العديد من السياقات الأخرى حيث تظهر المتجهات والمصفوفات.
سننتقل بعد ذلك إلى المعلومات الكمومية، وتحديداً سنناقش
تمثيل الحالات الكمومية كمتجهات،
نوع بسيط من القياس يسمى قياس الأساس القياسي، والعمليات الأحادية، التي تصف تغييرات زمنية
منفصلة في الأنظمة الكمومية.
مرة أخرى، كل ذلك في إطار
الأنظمة المفردة.
قبل أن نبدأ بالدرس نفسه، سيكون من المفيد التوضيح أن هناك في الواقع وصفين
للمعلومات الكمومية، الوصف المبسط، وهو ما سنركز
عليه في هذا الدرس
وطوال هذه الوحدة الأولى والوصف العام، الذي يُغطى في وحدة لاحقة، تحديداً في
الوحدة الثالثة من السلسلة.
الوصف المبسط،
وفياً لاسمه، أبسط ويُتعلم
عادة أولاً.
في الوصف المبسط، كما أشرت سابقاً، الحالات الكمومية تُمثل بمتجهات والعمليات تُمثل
بمصفوفات أحادية.
هذا الوصف للمعلومات
الكمومية كافٍ لفهم
معظم الخوارزميات الكمومية، على سبيل المثال،
لذا فهو ليس مبسطاً بشكل مفرط، إنه الشيء الحقيقي.
ومع ذلك، كما سنكتشف
بمرور الوقت، لديه بعض القيود.
على سبيل المثال، إذا أردنا
نمذجة تأثيرات الضوضاء على الأنظمة الكمومية، فإن هذا الوصف يتبين أنه غير كافٍ.
الوصف العام، من
ناحية أخرى، أكثر عمومية وفي النهاية، أكثر
قوة بالمعنى الرياضي.
في هذا الوصف، الحالات الكمومية تُمثل بفئة خاصة من المصفوفات
تسمى مصفوفات الكثافة،
ويمكن وصف فئة أعم من
القياسات والعمليات بما في ذلك
الضوضاء، على سبيل المثال.
إنه متسق تماماً مع
الوصف المبسط وفي الحقيقة، يمكنكم اعتبار
الوصف المبسط بشكل أساسي
كحالة خاصة من
الوصف العام، ويتضمن أيضاً المعلومات الكلاسيكية كحالة خاصة.
وهو أيضاً جميل حقاً
في طريقة عمله، لذا أشجعكم بشدة على تعلم هذا الوصف العام
عندما يحين الوقت المناسب، لكن الوصف المبسط هو المكان الأكثر طبيعية للبدء، ولذلك هذا ما سنفعله.
سنبدأ بالحديث عن المعلومات الكلاسيكية مع التركيز على الجوانب
من المعلومات الكلاسيكية الأكثر صلة
بالمعلومات الكمومية
والطريقة التي
توصف بها رياضياً.
تخيلوا أن لدينا
نظاماً فيزيائياً أو جهازاً من نوع ما يخزن المعلومات.
سنعطي هذا النظام الاسم X، لكن لا يوجد شيء
مهم بخصوص هذا الاسم.
يمكننا استخدام أي اسم
آخر إذا أردنا، لكن فقط لاختيار اسم،
سنسمي النظام X.
سنضع افتراضاً حول X، وهو أن هناك
مجموعة محدودة من الحالات الكلاسيكية التي يمكن أن يكون فيها X
في أي لحظة معينة.
هنا، عندما أشير إلى حالة كلاسيكية، أعني تكوين النظام الذي يمكن التعرف عليه
ووصفه بشكل لا لبس فيه
بدون أي غموض أو خطأ.
حقاً، هذا شيء يمكنكم التفكير فيه بشكل حدسي. على المستوى الرياضي، نحدد ببساطة
مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية،
نختارها كما نريد أو بأي طريقة تصف
الجهاز الذي نعمل معه بشكل أفضل.
دعونا نعطي الاسم سيغما
لمجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية هذه، ومرة أخرى دعوني أؤكد
أننا نفترض أن سيغما مجموعة محدودة.
مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية
لهذا النظام X ليست كبيرة بلا نهاية مثل
مجموعة كل الأعداد الطبيعية.
إنها محدودة، وهذا مجرد
افتراض نضعه.
على سبيل المثال، يمكن أن يكون X بتاً، وفي هذه الحالة، مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية هي المجموعة التي تحتوي على
عنصرين: صفر وواحد.
أحياناً نشير إلى هذه
المجموعة بالأبجدية الثنائية.
مثال آخر هو أن X
نرد عادي ذو ستة أوجه، وفي هذه الحالة، الحالات الكلاسيكية هي الأرقام من واحد إلى ستة.
بالطبع، نحن نتحدث
عن تجريد هنا.
نرد حقيقي ذو ستة أوجه قد
يكون له العديد من السمات المختلفة مثل موقعه الدقيق
واتجاهه،
ودرجة حرارته، وهكذا. لكن فيما يتعلق بالمعلومات الأكثر صلة عادة عندما نتحدث عن نرد ذي ستة أوجه،
الحالات الكلاسيكية هي
الأرقام من واحد إلى ستة التي يشير إليها عدد النقاط على أي وجه من أوجه النرد يكون متجهاً للأعلى.
إذا كان X مفتاحاً على
مروحة كهربائية عادية قد تكون لديكم في منزلكم، فربما الحالات الكلاسيكية
هي الإعدادات: عالٍ،
متوسط، منخفض ومطفأ.
هذه مجرد أمثلة. يمكننا تخيل أنظمة لها مجموعات حالات
كلاسيكية مختلفة عن هذه، لكن آمل أنها توصل الفكرة
بأن مفهوم الحالة الكلاسيكية هذا شيء يجب أن يكون
مألوفاً ويمكن فهمه بعبارات بسيطة وحدسية.
رياضياً، مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية
هي مجرد مجموعة محدودة، وبالطبع، يجب أن تكون هذه المجموعة
غير فارغة أيضاً.
يجب أن تكون هناك
حالة كلاسيكية واحدة على الأقل يمكن أن يكون فيها النظام ويجب أن تكون هناك
حالتان كلاسيكيتان على الأقل
إذا كان النظام سيكون مفيداً على الإطلاق لتخزين المعلومات.
الآن، في بعض الحالات، قد نعرف أن X
في حالة معينة، لكن في كثير من الحالات،
التي تنشأ في إطار
معالجة المعلومات، قد يكون هناك غموض حول الحالة الكلاسيكية
لنظام في لحظة معينة
بحيث يكون لكل حالة كلاسيكية ممكنة احتمال مرتبط بها.
على سبيل المثال، إذا كان X بتاً، فربما يكون X في الحالة الكلاسيكية صفر
باحتمال ثلاثة أرباع ويكون في الحالة واحد
باحتمال ربع.
سنشير إلى هذا
كحالة احتمالية، ويمكننا التعبير عن
هذه الحالة الاحتمالية، كما ترون هنا،
ببساطة بالإشارة إلى
الاحتمالات للحالات الكلاسيكية المختلفة.
طريقة أكثر إيجازاً للتعبير
عن هذه الحالة الاحتمالية هي بمتجه، تحديداً التمثيل
الذي ترونه هنا
هو متجه عمودي، وهذا المتجه يشير
إلى الاحتمالات للحالتين الكلاسيكيتين الممكنتين.
لنكون أكثر تحديداً، المدخل الأول يشير
إلى احتمال أن يكون X في الحالة صفر، والمدخل الثاني يخبرنا
بالاحتمال
لأن يكون النظام في الحالة واحد. هذا ببساطة هو الترتيب الطبيعي للأبجدية الثنائية،
أو على الأقل، هو الطريقة التي
تعلمنا القيام بها. الصفر أولاً والواحد ثانياً.
من الآن فصاعداً، سنستخدم
مصطلح متجه الاحتمال للإشارة إلى متجه مثل هذا.
تحديداً، هو متجه مدخلاته كلها
أعداد حقيقية غير سالبة وحيث مجموع
المدخلات يساوي واحد،
لذا من المنطقي
اعتبار هذه المدخلات احتمالات.
هنا في هذا المثال، يوجد مدخلان فقط لأن هناك حالتان
كلاسيكيتان فقط للنظام الذي نتحدث عنه،
لكن بشكل عام، يمكن أن يكون
هناك أي عدد من المدخلات مع الفهم
بأن هناك مدخلاً واحداً لكل حالة كلاسيكية
لأي نظام نتحدث عنه.
سنستمر في مناقشة
المعلومات الكلاسيكية ومتجهات الاحتمال
وما إلى ذلك بعد لحظات، لكن أولاً، سيكون من المفيد جداً
تقديم بعض الترميز
لوصف المتجهات المعروف بترميز Dirac.
في الواقع، هذا مجرد الجزء الأول
من ترميز Dirac.
هناك جانبان آخران
من ترميز Dirac سنراهما بعد قليل
في الدرس.
هذا الترميز سيكون
محورياً جداً في الطريقة التي نصف بها المعلومات الكمومية، لذا من الضروري
فهم كيف يعمل،
لكن لحسن الحظ، هو بسيط جداً وليس له
أي علاقة تحديداً بالمعلومات الكمومية،
لذا يمكننا تقديمه الآن
في السياق المألوف للمعلومات الكلاسيكية.
كما سبق، نفترض أن لدينا مجموعة سيغما من
الحالات الكلاسيكية لنظام ما، ولنفترض
أن لدينا ترتيباً
لهذه الحالات الكلاسيكية، تماماً كما أشرنا إلى
ترتيب الأبجدية الثنائية
في المثال السابق. طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك
هي أن عناصر سيغما توضع في تناظر
مع الأعداد الصحيحة
من واحد إلى عدد
العناصر الموجودة في سيغما، وهو ما يعنيه هذا الترميز هنا مع شريطين حول سيغما.
هذا هو عدد
العناصر في المجموعة سيغما.
إذاً هناك حالة أولى،
وحالة ثانية، وهكذا.
الترتيب المحدد أو
التناظر الذي نختاره لن يكون مهماً كثيراً في الواقع.
ما هو مهم حقاً هو
أن لدينا ترتيباً ونلتزم به.
للعديد من مجموعات الحالات
الكلاسيكية التي سنصادفها، سيكون هناك ترتيب قياسي تماماً كما لدينا مع
الأبجدية الثنائية،
وإذا لم يكن هناك ترتيب قياسي، يمكننا ببساطة اختيار واحد.
لكن مهما كان، الفهم هو أننا نلتزم به.
الآن، إليكم الترميز
الذي يتم تقديمه.
لأي اختيار لحالة كلاسيكية
a من مجموعتنا سيغما، نكتب هذا هنا، والذي يُقرأ ket a
ليعني المتجه العمودي
الذي يحتوي على واحد في المدخل المقابل لـ a وصفر لجميع المدخلات الأخرى.
على سبيل المثال، إذا عدنا
إلى الأبجدية الثنائية، التي كما قد تكونون خمنتم، هي مثال مهم جداً
سنعود إليه مراراً وتكراراً. فإن ket صفر وket واحد هما المتجهان المعرفان هنا.
ket صفر هو المتجه
الذي يحتوي على واحد في المدخل المقابل للحالة الكلاسيكية صفر، وهو المدخل الأول،
وصفر لجميع المدخلات الأخرى، وفي هذه الحالة، هناك
مدخل واحد آخر فقط.
بالمثل، ket واحد هو
هذا المتجه هنا حيث لدينا واحد في
المدخل المقابل لواحد،
وهو المدخل الثاني، وصفر لجميع المدخلات الأخرى، والتي مرة أخرى هي مدخل واحد فقط.
إليكم مثالاً آخر. في هذا المثال، لدينا
مجموعة حالات كلاسيكية سيغما تقابل الأنواع الأربعة
في مجموعة أوراق اللعب القياسية: السباتي والديناري والكوبة والبستوني.
في هذه الحالة، لا يوجد حقاً
ترتيب متفق عليه عالمياً لهذه الأنواع.
للعديد من ألعاب الورق، لا يوجد ترتيب على الإطلاق. هي مجرد أربعة أنواع مختلفة وهذا كل ما يهم، وهناك ألعاب ورق مختلفة
ترتب هذه الأنواع
بطرق مختلفة، لكن هذا لا يهم حقاً.
يمكننا ببساطة اختيار
ترتيب مثل الذي ترونه هنا.
هذا يصادف أنه الترتيب الأبجدي وفقاً لأسماء هذه الأنواع الأربعة مكتوبة بالإنجليزية،
بافتراض أننا اخترنا
هذا الترتيب بالذات، فإننا نعرف هذه المتجهات الأربعة: ket سباتي، ket ديناري،
ket كوبة، وket بستوني
كما ترون هنا، وهذه المتجهات تتوافق
مع الوصف العام الذي ترونه هنا في الأعلى.
بالنظر إلى أننا اخترنا
هذا الترتيب بالذات لهذه الأنواع الأربعة.
يمكننا فعل الشيء نفسه لأي مجموعة حالات
كلاسيكية نختارها.
مع الأخذ بعين الاعتبار أن مجموعة الحالات
الكلاسيكية تعني دائماً مجموعة محدودة وغير فارغة.
المتجهات من هذا الشكل
تسمى متجهات الأساس القياسي، وهي حقيقة أساسية جداً عن المتجهات أن كل متجه يمكن التعبير عنه
بطريقة فريدة
كتركيبة خطية
من متجهات الأساس القياسي.
على سبيل المثال، بالعودة إلى المثال من قبل لحظات، متجه الاحتمال
الذي رأيناه يمكن التعبير عنه
كما ترون هنا. هي في الأساس مجرد طريقة بديلة للتعبير عن المتجهات
ستكون مفيدة جداً لعدة أسباب فيما بعد.
ومع هذا الترميز الآن بين أيدينا، لنعد إلى مناقشة
المعلومات الكلاسيكية والحالات الاحتمالية على وجه الخصوص.
ولننظر فيما يحدث
عندما نقيس نظاماً وهو في حالة احتمالية ما.
قد لا نشير عادة
إلى القياس أو فعل قياس
شيء ما في سياق كلاسيكي، لكن المصطلح منطقي.
في جوهره، عندما نتحدث
عن قياس النظام X في هذا السياق، نعني فقط أننا ننظر إليه ونتعرف على أي حالة يكون فيها.
بالطبع، عندما ننظر إلى النظام، لا نرى حالة احتمالية، نرى حالة كلاسيكية،
والحالة الكلاسيكية
المحددة التي نراها هي واحدة يمكننا
تخيل أنها اختيرت عشوائياً وفقاً للاحتمالات.
الآن، قد تعترضون على
أسس فلسفية على فكرة أن الحالة الكلاسيكية التي نراها تم اختيارها بطريقة ما عشوائياً
في لحظة القياس أو النظر إلى النظام، النظام كان ببساطة في حالة
كلاسيكية معينة طوال الوقت
ونحن صادف أننا
علمنا ما كانت الحالة، لكن من أجل التفكير في الإطار الرياضي
الذي نعمل به،
لا بأس من التفكير فيه بهذه الطريقة والقيام بذلك سيسمح لنا بإجراء مقارنة مع
المعلومات الكمومية بعد قليل.
لنفترض أن الحالة
الكلاسيكية التي نراها هي الحالة الكلاسيكية a، والتي يمكن أن تكون أي حالة في مجموعتنا سيغما.
هذا يغير الحالة الاحتمالية
لـ X بشكل عام، على الأقل من وجهة نظرنا.
الاحتمالات لم تعد
لها أهمية لأننا نعرف الآن ما هي
الحالة الكلاسيكية لـ X.
إنها a، ولم يعد هناك
أي غموض حول هذا.
لذا سنقول الآن هذا:
أن احتمال أن يكون النظام في الحالة a هو واحد.
نعرف هذا لأننا نظرنا إليه للتو ورأينا أن الحالة الكلاسيكية هي a، لذا الحالة الاحتمالية الجديدة لـ X هي واحدة
يكون فيها احتمال
أن تكون في الحالة الكلاسيكية a يساوي واحد.
وتلك الحالة الاحتمالية يمثلها
متجه الاحتمال ket a.
لدينا واحد في المدخل المقابل للحالة الكلاسيكية a وصفر في جميع المدخلات الأخرى.
على سبيل المثال، إذا نظرنا
مرة أخرى في الحالة التي يكون فيها X بتاً ولدينا نفس
الحالة الاحتمالية كما سبق،
فإذا قسنا X، يمكننا تخيل أن
انتقالاً يحدث.
باحتمال ثلاثة أرباع، نرى الحالة الكلاسيكية صفر، وبالقياس ننتقل إلى ket صفر
كحالتنا الاحتمالية،
وباحتمال ربع، ننتقل إلى ket واحد.
يمكنكم التفكير في هذا كانتقال في المعرفة إذا أردتم بدلاً من انتقال
فيزيائي فعلي،
لكن المهم من أجل
هذا الدرس هو إدراك كيف تعمل الرياضيات.
إنها في الواقع بديهية نوعاً ما، لكن بإدراك هذه البداهة، قد يبدو الوصف المماثل
للإطار الكمومي
أقل غموضاً بقليل.
ملاحظة أخيرة هي أنه بالنسبة لشخص آخر لم يصادف أن رأى ما كانت
الحالة الكلاسيكية لـ X عندما قسناه،
الحالة الاحتمالية
بطبيعة الحال لن تتغير نتيجة لقيامنا بالقياس.
لا بأس بذلك. يمكن لأفراد مختلفين أن يكون
لديهم معرفة مختلفة بنظام معين ويختاروا بالتالي
حالات احتمالية مختلفة
لتمثيل
معرفتهم بذلك النظام.
في الجزء الأخير من هذه المناقشة للمعلومات الكلاسيكية، سنتحدث عن العمليات الكلاسيكية التي يمكن إجراؤها على نظام،
بدءاً بالعمليات الحتمية.
عندما نجري عملية على نظام، تتغير حالته عموماً نتيجة لذلك، وفي هذا السياق، كلمة حتمية تعني
أن نتيجة إجراء
العملية تعتمد كلياً على أي حالة كلاسيكية
كان فيها النظام
قبل إجراء العملية.
بعبارة أخرى، لا يوجد
عنصر صدفة عند إجراء عملية
حتمية، لذا لا توجد عشوائية
أو غموض.
بالمصطلحات الرياضية، العمليات الحتمية
توصف بالدوال.
كل دالة f من الشكل
الذي ترونه هنا، والذي يعني أن كلاً من مدخل ومخرج الدالة
يتوافقان مع عناصر من
مجموعة حالاتنا الكلاسيكية سيغما تصف عملية حتمية.
الحالة الكلاسيكية a
تتحول إلى الحالة f(a) لكل اختيار للحالة a.
لكل دالة f من هذا الشكل، ستكون هناك دائماً مصفوفة فريدة M تحقق هذا الشرط
الذي ترونه هنا،
وهو أنه بضرب
M في المتجه ket a يعطينا المتجه ket f(a)،
وهذا صحيح لكل
اختيار لحالة كلاسيكية a.
ليس من الصعب كتابة
وصف صريح لـ M بالنظر إلى أي دالة f
من هذا الشكل اخترناها.
ستحتوي دائماً على واحد
واحد بالضبط في كل عمود مع كل مدخل آخر يساوي صفر.
وإليكم الصيغة. المدخل b, a من M يساوي واحد إذا كان b يساوي f(a)
وبخلاف ذلك، يساوي صفر، وبهذا نعني
أن هذا هو مدخل M الذي صفه يتوافق مع b
وعموده يتوافق مع a.
سنرى بعض الأمثلة بعد لحظات، وسنرى لماذا تعمل هذه الصيغة.
الآن، قد لا يكون واضحاً لماذا نريد أخذ دالة والتعبير عنها كمصفوفة بهذا الشكل،
لكن من المنطقي فعل ذلك. أحد الأسباب، وربما هو السبب الرئيسي، هو أنه إذا كان لدينا نظام
في حالة احتمالية
وأجرينا عملية حتمية
على ذلك النظام، فإن الحالة الاحتمالية
الناتجة يمكن الحصول عليها
بضرب المصفوفة في المتجه، أي إذا كان نظامنا
في حالة احتمالية
ممثلة
بمتجه احتمال ما v وأجرينا العملية الحتمية
الموصوفة بـ M
على ذلك النظام، فإن الحالة الاحتمالية الناتجة ستكون M ضرب v.
هنا بالمناسبة، هذا السهم مع
شريط صغير عليه هكذا هو مجرد ترميز شائع في الرياضيات للإشارة إلى كيفية
تحول شيء ما
إلى شيء آخر. يمكنكم استخدام سهم عادي، لكن هذا اصطلاحي
ومعروف وربما أكثر تحديداً من مجرد سهم، والذي يمكن أن يعني أشياء كثيرة مختلفة.
الآن لنلقي نظرة على مثال أو مجموعة أمثلة في الحقيقة.
لننظر فيما يحدث عندما نأخذ مجموعة حالاتنا الكلاسيكية سيغما لتكون مرة أخرى الأبجدية الثنائية.
لا يوجد الكثير من الدوال المختلفة من الشكل الذي ناقشناه عندما تكون هذه مجموعة حالاتنا الكلاسيكية ولنكون أكثر دقة، هناك أربع
دوال فقط من هذا الشكل.
هنا، تلك الدوال الأربع موصوفة بما يسمى جداول القيم الخاصة بها.
الجدول الأول يصف
الدالة الأولى، التي سميناها f1.
لكل مدخل ممكن على اليسار، نسرد المخرج
المقابل على اليمين، لذا f1 من صفر تساوي صفر،
وf1 من واحد تساوي أيضاً صفر، أي أن f1 هي
دالة الصفر الثابتة.
تأخذ دائماً القيمة صفر.
الدالة الثانية f2
هي دالة الهوية.
المخرج يساوي دائماً المدخل كما ترون من الجدول الثاني.
الدالة الثالثة f3
موصوفة بالجدول الثالث.
f3 من صفر تساوي واحد، وf3 من واحد تساوي صفر.
هذه الدالة معروفة
أكثر بدالة النفي أو النفي المنطقي.
أحياناً نسميها أيضاً قلب البت لأنها تقلب الصفر
إلى واحد والواحد إلى صفر.
الدالة الأخيرة f4 هي
مرة أخرى دالة ثابتة تماماً مثل الأولى، لكن هذه هي دالة الواحد الثابتة
لأنها تأخذ دائماً القيمة واحد.
وتلك هي الدوال الأربع الوحيدة من الأبجدية الثنائية إلى نفسها.
إليكم المصفوفات الأربع التي تقابل هذه الدوال الأربع الموصوفة بالصيغة
من قبل،
التي يمكنكم رؤيتها هنا، وإذا رغبتم، يمكنكم إيقاف الفيديو والتحقق من ذلك.
تذكروا فقط أنه مع المصفوفات، ترتيب المؤشرات دائماً الصفوف أولاً ثم الأعمدة.
لذا المدخل b, a يقابل
الصف b والعمود a أو الصف الذي يقابل
الحالة الكلاسيكية b
والعمود الذي يقابل
الحالة الكلاسيكية a.
فمثلاً، إذا نظرنا
إلى الدالة الأولى، لدينا f1 من صفر تساوي صفر
وبالتالي، المدخل
صفر-صفر من M1 يساوي واحد.
أما المدخل واحد-صفر
الذي هو هنا يساوي صفر، ويمكنكم فعل الشيء نفسه لحالة
يكون فيها المدخل يساوي واحد وبالمثل، للدوال
الثلاث الأخرى.
يمكنكم أيضاً التحقق من أن
هذه الصيغة من قبل صحيحة ويمكنكم ببساطة المرور واحدة تلو الأخرى على كل
الاحتمالات المختلفة للتحقق من ذلك.
وفي الحقيقة، إذا فكرتم في طريقة عمل
ضرب المصفوفات، يمكنكم في الواقع ملاحظة ذلك بالنظر فقط.
عندما تضربون مصفوفة في متجه أساس قياسي مثل هذا، يمكنكم تخيل أنكم
تأخذون المدخل
وتسقطونه في
أعلى إحدى المصفوفات في أي عمود يقابل
الحالة الكلاسيكية
داخل الـ ket، والمخرج الذي
تحصلون عليه هو ببساطة ذلك العمود كمتجه احتمال.
فمثلاً، M3 مضروبة في ket
صفر تعطيكم صفر، واحد
كمتجه احتمال، وهو ket واحد.
M3 مضروبة في ket
واحد تعطيكم واحد، صفر، وهو ket صفر وهكذا.
سنناقش العمليات على
الحالات الاحتمالية أكثر بعد قليل، لكن أولاً لنقدم الجزء الثاني من ترميز Dirac.
هذا سيكون مفيداً
للحديث عن العمليات والتفكير فيها كمصفوفات، وسيكون أيضاً أداة قياسية
سنستمر في استخدامها فيما بعد. الإعداد تماماً كما كان من قبل.
لدينا أي مجموعة حالات كلاسيكية سيغما نعمل معها ونفترض أن لدينا طريقة ما
لترتيب تلك الحالات الكلاسيكية.
ثم نكتب هذا الشيء
الذي ترونه هنا حيث هذه المرة
الشريط الزاوي على اليسار بدلاً من اليمين ليعني
المتجه الأفقي الذي يحتوي على واحد
في المدخل الذي
يقابل a وصفر لجميع المدخلات الأخرى المقابلة لجميع
الحالات الكلاسيكية الأخرى.
لذا الفرق بين
هذا الشيء وket a هو أن هذا متجه أفقي
وket a متجه عمودي،
لكن بخلاف ذلك، المتجهات
معرفة بطريقة مشابهة.
نقرأ هذا bra a، لست متأكداً إن كان
من المفترض أن يكون مضحكاً، لكن الفكرة هي أن الاسمين bra وket
هما نصفا كلمة bracket، وسنتحدث أكثر
عن ذلك بعد لحظة.
لكن أولاً، لنلقي نظرة
على مثال سريع جداً.
للأبجدية الثنائية، لدينا أن bra صفر هو
هذا المتجه الأفقي هنا مماثل لـ ket a،
إلا أنه متجه أفقي
بدلاً من متجه عمودي وbra واحد هو هذا المتجه هنا.
الآن بشكل عام، إذا ضربنا متجهاً
أفقياً في متجه عمودي، بالتفكير فيهما كمصفوفات
يصادف أن لها
صف واحد فقط أو عمود واحد فقط، نحصل على مصفوفة واحد في واحد، والتي يمكن
اعتبارها قيمة عددية.
هنا بالمناسبة، يجب أن
تعتبروا هذه النجوم ممثلة لأعداد عشوائية.
على وجه الخصوص، إذا
ضربنا المتجه الأفقي bra a في المتجه العمودي ket b،
فهناك شيئان يمكن أن يحدثا.
أحدهما أن a وb متساويان، أي أنهما نفس الحالة الكلاسيكية، وفي هذه الحالة ستتطابق الآحاد
ويكون الجداء يساوي واحد أو يمكن أن يكون
a وb مختلفين،
وبالتالي الآحاد لا تتطابق والجداء يساوي صفر.
طريقة بسيطة للتعبير
عن هذه الملاحظات هي هكذا هنا.
وفقط للحفاظ على الترتيب، نكتب هذا الجداء هكذا مع شريط واحد فقط في المنتصف وهو يعني نفس
الشيء تماماً كهذا هنا.
والآن يمكنكم رؤية كيف
أن bra وket يجتمعان ليشكلا bracket، والذي
يسمى أيضاً الجداء الداخلي،
وهذا شيء
مهم جداً سنعود إليه
في الدرس الثالث.
ضرب متجه عمودي
في متجه أفقي، من ناحية أخرى، يعطينا مصفوفة كما ترون هنا.
فمثلاً، بالعودة مرة أخرى
إلى الأبجدية الثنائية، إذا ضربنا ket صفر في bra صفر،
ما نحصل عليه هو هذه المصفوفة هنا، ويمكننا المرور على
الاحتمالات الأخرى لنرى ماذا يحدث.
ket صفر ضرب bra واحد يعطينا
هذه المصفوفة هنا حيث الواحد انتقل
الآن إلى هذا الموضع.
ket واحد، bra صفر يبدو هكذا وهذا هو ket واحد، bra واحد.
ما نراه يحدث هو أن هناك واحد وحيد في مصفوفة باقيها أصفار، وموضع ذلك الواحد
يتحدد بالحالات
الكلاسيكية التي نختارها في الـ bra والـ ket.
بشكل أدق، وهذا
صحيح بشكل عام، لأي اختيار لمجموعة حالات كلاسيكية، المصفوفة التي نحصل عليها بضرب
ket a في bra b
هي المصفوفة التي تحتوي على واحد في المدخل a, b وصفر لجميع المدخلات الأخرى.
والآن بما أن لدينا كلاً من
الجزء الأول والثاني من ترميز Dirac، لدينا أداة مفيدة جداً للربط بين العمليات والمصفوفات.
لنعد بإيجاز
إلى العمليات الحتمية ونتذكر أنه قبل قليل
في الدرس،
ذُكر أنه لكل دالة f من
هذا الشكل هنا، لدينا عملية حتمية تحول a إلى f(a)
لكل حالة كلاسيكية ممكنة a. وقلنا أنه لأي
دالة كهذه، هناك دائماً مصفوفة فريدة
M تعمل هكذا
على حالات الأساس القياسي.
باستخدام ترميز Dirac، يمكننا الآن التعبير عن هذه المصفوفة بسهولة كما ترون هنا،
ويمكننا رؤية كيف أنه أحياناً
من الممكن العمل مع المصفوفات بالكامل
ضمن إطار ترميز Dirac
دون الحاجة إلى التحويل صراحة
إلى متجهات ومصفوفات، أي مستطيلات مملوءة بالأعداد.
في هذه الحالة، يمكننا التحقق من أن
الصيغة المطلوبة صحيحة بضرب M في ket a.
نعوض
تعبيرنا عن M هكذا ويمكننا إزالة الأقواس ودمج bra
b مع ket a هكذا.
وذلك لأن ضرب
المصفوفات خطي، في هذه الحالة في المتغير الأول وتجميعي لذا يمكننا إزالة الأقواس.
والآن، تذكروا أن لدينا a ثابت نتحدث عنه بينما نجمع على كل
الاختيارات الممكنة لـ b،
هذا الـ bracket هنا
سيكون دائماً يساوي صفر عندما لا يكون b مساوياً لـ a، لذا لن تكون هناك أي
مساهمة في المجموع،
وعندما يكون b مساوياً لـ a، سيكون الـ bracket يساوي واحد وبالتالي سيتبقى لنا
هذا الحد هنا.
تلك هي الصيغة التي أردناها ولدينا طريقة بسيطة وأنيقة جداً للتعبير عن دالة كمصفوفة.
بالإضافة إلى العمليات الحتمية، لدينا أيضاً عمليات
تقدم بذاتها عشوائية أو غموضاً حول
الحالة الكلاسيكية لنظام.
نستخدم مصطلح عملية احتمالية للإشارة إلى عمليات كهذه، ولنكون دقيقين، عندما نقول عملية احتمالية،
نعني عمليات قد
تقدم عشوائية، لذا العمليات الحتمية هي في الواقع حالة خاصة
من العمليات الاحتمالية
التي لا يصادف أنها
تقدم أي عشوائية.
إليكم مثالاً بسيطاً حيث
يتم تقديم بعض العشوائية.
هذه عملية على بت واحد. الطريقة التي تعمل بها هي أنه إذا كانت الحالة الكلاسيكية
للبت صفر،
فلا يحدث شيء. البت يبقى صفر، لكن إذا كانت الحالة
الكلاسيكية للبت واحد، فإن العملية تقلب البت إلى صفر
باحتمال يساوي 1/2.
لا يوجد اسم خاص
لهذه العملية، على الأقل ليس على حد علمي.
هي مجرد مثال، لكن يمكنكم تخيل إجراء
هذه العملية على بت.
تماماً مثل العمليات الحتمية، العمليات الاحتمالية يمكن
تمثيلها بمصفوفات وتأثيرها على الحالات الاحتمالية
يُعطى بضرب المصفوفة في المتجه تماماً كما سبق.
هذه المرة، ليس بالضرورة أن المصفوفات تحتوي على واحد واحد بالضبط في كل عمود وأصفار فيما عدا ذلك.
العمليات الاحتمالية
تُمثل بشكل أعم بمصفوفات عشوائية.
هذه مصفوفات مدخلاتها كلها
أعداد حقيقية غير سالبة وحيث المدخلات في
كل عمود مجموعها واحد.
وهذا مكافئ للقول
بأن المصفوفات العشوائية هي مصفوفات حيث كل عمود
يشكل متجه احتمال.
هذا منطقي عندما تفكرون في
تأثير مصفوفة على متجه أساس قياسي.
تختارون أي
حالة كلاسيكية تريدون وتتخيلون إسقاط تلك الحالة في أعلى المصفوفة في أي عمود يقابل
تلك الحالة الكلاسيكية،
وذلك العمود يخبركم ما هي
الحالة الاحتمالية التي تخرج كمتجه احتمال.
العملية الاحتمالية
في مثالنا، على سبيل المثال، موصوفة بهذه المصفوفة هنا.
إذا أجرينا هذه العملية
على الحالة الكلاسيكية صفر، فإن الحالة الاحتمالية التي نحصل عليها تُعطى بالعمود الأول،
وهي مرة أخرى الحالة الكلاسيكية صفر أو بالتكافؤ، الحالة الاحتمالية
حيث صفر يحدث باحتمال واحد.
إذا أجرينا بدلاً من ذلك هذه العملية على الحالة الكلاسيكية واحد، فإننا فعلياً نجعل البت عشوائياً وبالتالي نحصل على
متجه الاحتمال هذا هنا
حيث الاحتمال لكل
من الحالتين الممكنتين يساوي 1/2.
بشكل عام، إذا أجرينا هذه العملية على أي حالة احتمالية، فإن التأثير هو في الأساس
مجرد متوسط مرجح بين العمودين
لأن هذه هي طريقة عمل ضرب
المصفوفة في المتجه.
إنه خطي، لذا نأخذ ببساطة المتوسط بين
النتيجتين الممكنتين وفقاً لذلك.
عندما نفكر في العمليات
الاحتمالية بهذه الطريقة، من الطبيعي التفكير
فيها كأنها تقدم أو تحقن عشوائية.
يمكننا ببساطة قراءة الأعمدة واحداً تلو الآخر ونرى العشوائية
التي تقدمها لكل حالة كلاسيكية ممكنة.
يمكنكم أيضاً التفكير في
العمليات الاحتمالية بطريقة مختلفة قليلاً، وهي أنها اختيارات عشوائية لعمليات حتمية.
على سبيل المثال، في مثالنا، يمكننا التفكير في هذه العملية على أنها مكافئة
لرمي عملة عادلة
وإما إجراء
دالة الصفر الثابتة أو دالة الهوية
كل منهما باحتمال 1/2،
ويمكنكم رؤية ذلك معكوساً
هنا في هذه المعادلة.
هذا ممكن دائماً لأي
عملية احتمالية، وهو حدسي جداً.
إذا قمتم باختيارات عشوائية
كجزء من عملية ما، يمكنكم دائماً تخيل القيام بتلك الاختيارات العشوائية مسبقاً
ثم ترميز تلك
الاختيارات في مجموعة من العمليات الحتمية.
من المفيد أحياناً جداً التفكير في العمليات
الاحتمالية بهذه الطريقة، وسنرى مثالاً
على ذلك في درس من الدروس القادمة.
آخر شيء نقوله
عن المعلومات الكلاسيكية في هذا الدرس يتعلق بتركيب
العمليات الاحتمالية، وهو يعني ببساطة إجراء
واحدة بعد الأخرى.
لنفترض أن
لدينا نظاماً يسمى X وM1 حتى Mn هي مصفوفات عشوائية تمثل عمليات
احتمالية على X.
تخيلوا أولاً أن لدينا
متجه احتمال v، الذي يمثل حالة احتمالية
لـ X في لحظة ما، ثم نطبق أولاً
العملية الاحتمالية الأولى على X، المُمثلة بالمصفوفة M1، ثم نطبق العملية
الاحتمالية الثانية،
المُمثلة بـ M2.
إذا فعلنا ذلك، فإن
متجه الاحتمال الذي نحصل عليه بعد تطبيق العملية الأولى
فقط هو M1 ضرب v،
وعندما نطبق
العملية الثانية، متجه الاحتمال الناتج هو M2 مضروباً في أي متجه حصلنا عليه
بعد تطبيق M1. لذا يبدو هكذا.
الآن، ضرب المصفوفات
هو عملية تجميعية، مما يعني أنه لا يهم أين نضع هذه الأقواس.
لذا يمكننا بنفس السهولة
وضع الأقواس هكذا.
هذا بسيط جداً، لكنه مثير للاهتمام أيضاً لأنه يكشف أننا
يمكننا التفكير في العملية حيث نطبق M1 أولاً
ثم نطبق M2
كعملية واحدة.
بعبارة أخرى،
العملية الاحتمالية التي نحصل عليها بتركيب العملية الاحتمالية
الأولى والثانية تُمثل بجداء
المصفوفات، M2 ضرب M1،
وهذه نفس العملية بغض النظر عن الحالة الاحتمالية
التي بدأنا بها.
لا نحتاج لمعرفة أي شيء عن متجه الاحتمال v للتفكير في أو لوصف
هذه العملية المركبة.
لاحظوا أن الترتيب
هنا هو M2 على اليسار وM1 على اليمين، وذلك لأن
المصفوفة على اليمين، M1،
هي التي تُضرب
في المتجه v، بينما M2 تُضرب
في أي متجه نحصل عليه بعد الضرب بـ M1.
لذا يجب أن نأخذ بعين الاعتبار دائماً أن الترتيب بمعنى ما
ينعكس.
العملية التي تُنفذ
أولاً هي التي على اليمين والعملية التي تُنفذ أخيراً أو في هذه الحالة ثانياً،
هي التي على اليسار.
إذا لم نتوقف عند العملية الثانية وطبقنا جميعها
بالترتيب بدءاً بالأولى وانتهاءً بالأخيرة، وهي Mn،
فإن تركيب كل
هذه العمليات معاً يُعطى بهذا الجداء
الذي ترونه هنا،
وترون أن الترتيب
مرة أخرى معكوس لنفس السبب تماماً كما سبق.
باختصار إذاً، تركيبات
العمليات الاحتمالية تُمثل بجداءات
المصفوفات العشوائية التي تمثلها.
مع الأخذ بعين الاعتبار أن هذا هو
ترتيب المصفوفات في الجداء.
ستحصلون دائماً على مصفوفة عشوائية بأخذ جداء
مصفوفات عشوائية كهذه، وأحياناً نعبر عن هذه الحقيقة
بالقول إن المصفوفات
العشوائية مغلقة تحت الضرب، والطريقة التي
يمكنكم التفكير بها هي أنه لا يمكنكم الخروج من
مجموعة المصفوفات العشوائية
بضربها لأن المجموعة مغلقة.
بالعودة إلى
ترتيب المصفوفات في هذا الجداء، من المهم ملاحظة أن
الترتيب يهم فعلاً.
ضرب المصفوفات ليس تبديلياً. إذا غيرتم ترتيب
المصفوفات في الجداء، قد تغيرون النتيجة،
ولا نحتاج للبحث أبعد من العمليات الحتمية
لنرى ذلك.
إليكم مثالاً بسيطاً لمصفوفتين
عشوائيتين، كلتاهما تمثلان
عمليات حتمية حيث الترتيب يهم.
M1 تمثل دالة الصفر الثابتة. بافتراض أننا نتخيل أن هاتين العمليتين على بتات، تماماً كما في المثال من قبل.
M2 تمثل عملية
النفي أو قلب البت.
إذا أجريتم M1 أولاً
ثم M2، النتيجة هي هذه المصفوفة هنا، التي تمثل
دالة الواحد الثابتة.
إذا ضبطتم بتاً على صفر
ثم قلبتموه، فهذا مثل مجرد
ضبط ذلك البت على واحد.
من ناحية أخرى، إذا أجريتم M2 أولاً
ثم M1، هذه هي النتيجة هنا،
وهذا منطقي لأنه إذا قلبتم بتاً
ثم ضبطتموه على صفر، فهذا مثل
مجرد ضبطه على صفر.
لم يكن مهماً أنكم قلبتموه. من الواضح أن هاتين
المصفوفتين ليستا متطابقتين، ولدينا مثال بسيط
جداً يكشف
أن الترتيب يهم فعلاً. بالطبع، هذا ليس مفاجئاً على الإطلاق.
كلنا نعرف أن الترتيب الذي تُنفذ فيه
العمليات يهم أو على الأقل يمكن أن يهم.
على سبيل المثال، إذا أشعلتم
عود ثقاب ثم نفختم عليه، النتيجة مختلفة جداً
عن النفخ على العود أولاً
ثم إشعاله. عند هذه النقطة، تحدثنا كثيراً
عن المعلومات الكلاسيكية والآن حان الوقت أخيراً
لمناقشة المعلومات الكمومية.
وما سنجده هو أنه
من الناحية الرياضية، المعلومات الكمومية تعمل
بطريقة مشابهة جداً للمعلومات الكلاسيكية
مع بعض الاختلافات الجوهرية.
الاختلاف الجوهري الأول
يكون عند البداية مباشرة، كيف نعرف حالة، في هذه الحالة حالة كمومية لنظام،
وهناك إحساس بأن هذا الاختيار الواحد - كيف
نعرف الحالة الكمومية - يحدد إلى حد كبير كيف
تعمل المعلومات الكمومية.
سنعرف أيضاً كيف
تعمل القياسات والعمليات، وفي الدرس القادم سنناقش كيف
تعمل المعلومات الكمومية ليس فقط لأنظمة مفردة
بل لأنظمة متعددة،
لكن هذه الأشياء في الواقع
تتبع بشكل طبيعي جداً بمجرد أن يتم تأسيس مفهوم الحالة الكمومية لنظام مفرد
في عزلة.
إليكم التعريف. الحالة الكمومية لنظام تُمثل بمتجه عمودي يتم وضع مؤشراته
في تناظر مع الحالات
الكلاسيكية لذلك النظام.
لذا نفترض هنا أن
النظام الذي نتحدث عنه لديه مجموعة من الحالات الكلاسيكية، تماماً كما عندما تحدثنا
عن المعلومات الكلاسيكية
والحالات الاحتمالية. المدخلات في متجه حالة كمومية
هي أعداد مركبة بدلاً من الحالة الاحتمالية
حيث المدخلات هي
أعداد حقيقية غير سالبة.
وهذه المرة، مجموع القيم المطلقة
المربعة للمدخلات يجب أن يساوي واحد بدلاً من أن يكون المجموع يساوي واحد
كما لدينا في الحالة الاحتمالية.
الأعداد المركبة التي تظهر
في متجه حالة كمومية تسمى أحياناً سعات وتلعب دوراً
مشابهاً للاحتمالات،
لكنها ليست احتمالات وليس لها
نفس التفسير.
الآن، لا أستطيع إعطاءكم سبباً جيداً لماذا يجب تعريف الحالات الكمومية
هكذا سوى القول بأن
الفيزيائيين اكتشفوا
أن هذا التعريف
ذو صلة فيزيائية ويسمح لنا بوصف ونمذجة
الأنظمة الميكانيكية الكمومية.
بعبارة أخرى، نختار هذا التعريف
لأنه يعمل، وليس لأن هناك
أي أسباب محددة لماذا يجب تعريف الحالات الكمومية
هكذا.
فيما يتعلق
بالرياضيات لهذا المفهوم للحالة الكمومية، الخطوة الأولى نحو فهمه والعمل معه هي
تذكر هذا التعريف
للمعيار الإقليدي لمتجه، والذي يمكنكم التفكير فيه هندسياً كطول متجه، تماماً كما تفكرون في طول
متجه حقيقي ثنائي الأبعاد إذا رسمتموه على قطعة
ورق كسهم يبدأ من نقطة الأصل بالطريقة المعتادة.
تحديداً، إذا كان لدينا
متجه عمودي v هكذا، والذي نفترض أن مدخلاته
أعداد مركبة، ألفا واحد حتى ألفا n،
فإن المعيار الإقليدي لـ v يُعرّف كما ترون هنا.
هذا هو الترميز الذي
نستخدمه للمعيار الإقليدي بوضع هذين الشريطين المزدوجين حول أي متجه نتحدث عنه.
في هذه الحالة هو v، والطريقة التي يُعرّف بها المعيار الإقليدي هي أنه الجذر التربيعي لمجموع
القيم المطلقة المربعة
لمدخلات المتجه.
لذا طريقة أخرى لتعريف ما هو
متجه الحالة الكمومية هي أن متجه الحالة الكمومية هو متجه عمودي ذو
مدخلات أعداد مركبة
معياره الإقليدي يساوي واحد، أي أنه متجه وحدة بالنسبة للمعيار الإقليدي.
وذلك لأن مجموع
القيم المطلقة المربعة يساوي واحد إذا وفقط إذا كان المعيار
الإقليدي يساوي واحد.
الجذر التربيعي لا يغير شيئاً عندما يكون مجموع القيم
المطلقة المربعة يساوي واحد.
إذاً هذا ما هو متجه الحالة الكمومية. هو متجه عمودي بمؤشرات تقابل
الحالات الكلاسيكية لنظام
ذو مدخلات أعداد مركبة ومعيار إقليدي يساوي واحد.
ما يعنيه ذلك أو ما يتضمنه أو كيف يجب أن نفسر هذا
المفهوم هو مسألة مختلفة وبمعنى ما،
دراسة المعلومات
الكمومية والحوسبة هي استكشاف لما
يتضمنه هذا التعريف، على الأقل من حيث
معالجة المعلومات.
هذه ببساطة نقطة البداية.
كملاحظة جانبية، دعوني أذكر أن هناك
ما يسمى بمعايير أخرى غير المعيار الإقليدي وهذا الترميز هنا
مع الشريطين المزدوجين
حول متجه لا يعني دائماً
المعيار الإقليدي.
في سياقات مختلفة، هذا الترميز يمكن أن يشير
إلى معيار مختلف.
على سبيل المثال، مجموع
القيم المطلقة بدون تربيع أو جذر
تربيعي هو معيار مختلف،
يسمى غالباً المعيار الأول. هناك الكثير
من المعايير المختلفة في الحقيقة.
أحياناً سترون
هذا الترميز يُستخدم مع حرف سفلي بعد
المجموعة الثانية من الأشرطة يقدم مزيداً من المعلومات عن أي معيار نتحدث عنه.
وعندما نفعل ذلك، من الشائع جداً أن الرقم اثنان كحرف سفلي
يعني المعيار الإقليدي.
لكن في هذه السلسلة، عندما يكون لدينا
متجه عمودي كهذا، ترميز الشريطين المزدوجين وحده
يعني المعيار الإقليدي.
إليكم بعض الأمثلة
على متجهات الحالة الكمومية وهذه المتجهات تحديداً هي متجهات حالة qubit،
مما يعني أن
الحالات الكلاسيكية لنظامنا هي صفر وواحد.
كلمة qubit هي اختصار لـ quantum bit، وهي حقاً مجرد بت
يمكن أن يكون في حالة كمومية.
المثالان الأولان بسيطان جداً. متجهات الأساس القياسي
ket صفر وket واحد هي متجهات حالة كمومية.
كلاهما متجهان عموديان، والمؤشرات تقابل
الحالات الكلاسيكية صفر وواحد، ومدخلات هذه
المتجهات هي أعداد مركبة.
لهذين المتجهين بالذات، المدخلات هي صفر وواحد، وهي أعداد حقيقية، وفي الحقيقة هي أعداد صحيحة، لكنها أيضاً أعداد مركبة
يصادف أن جزءها
التخيلي يساوي صفر.
كل متجه لديه مدخل واحد يساوي واحد ومدخل واحد يساوي صفر.
لذا عندما نجمع القيم
المطلقة للمدخلات، نحصل على واحد في كلتا الحالتين.
لذا الشروط
المطلوبة لكي تكون هذه المتجهات متجهات حالة كمومية محققة.
المثالان التاليان هما حالتا qubit شائعتان جداً تسميان حالة الزائد وحالة الناقص.
تُرمز لهما كما
ترون هنا على الشاشة، إما بـ ket زائد
أو ket ناقص هكذا، وتُعرّفان
كما ترون هنا.
مرة أخرى، مدخلات هذه
المتجهات هي أعداد مركبة. هذه المرة هي إما واحد موجب على الجذر التربيعي لاثنين أو سالب واحد على الجذر التربيعي لاثنين،
وعندما نجمع
القيم المطلقة المربعة، نحصل على 1/2 زائد 1/2، وهو واحد.
بالمناسبة، وضع
علامة زائد أو ناقص داخل ket هكذا
قد يبدو غريباً بعض الشيء لأن هذه ليست حالات
كلاسيكية لنظامنا،
لكن هذا الترميز يُستخدم مع ذلك، وسنعود إلى هذا بعد لحظات.
لكن باختصار الآن، يمكننا استخدام ترميز Dirac لوضع أي اسم نريده لمتجه داخل ket.
المتجه لا يجب أن يكون
متجه أساس قياسي عندما نستخدم ترميز Dirac.
إليكم مثالاً أخيراً لحالة qubit
للحظة على أي حال.
إنه متجه حالة كمومية لـ qubit ليس له اسم خاص، وليس ذا أهمية خاصة.
مدخلات هذا المتجه هي واحد زائد اثنان ضرب i
على ثلاثة وسالب 2/3.
هذه أعداد مركبة، وإذا حسبتم
القيم المطلقة المربعة لهذين المدخلين، ستحصلون على 5/9 للأول
و4/9 للثاني. لذا مجموع القيم
المطلقة المربعة يساوي واحد.
وإليكم مثالاً أخيراً. هذه المرة لنظام
حالاته الكلاسيكية هي أنواع الورق الأربعة.
لا أعرف لماذا قد يكون لدينا نظام حالاته الكلاسيكية
هي أنواع الورق الأربعة في حالة كمومية، لكنه ممكن من حيث المبدأ
وهو مجرد مثال.
المدخلات المقابلة
للأنواع المختلفة هي 1/2 للسباتي، سالب
i على اثنين للديناري،
صفر للكوبة لأنها لا تظهر في المجموع وواحد على الجذر
التربيعي لاثنين للبستوني.
وإليكم كيف يبدو
كمتجه عمودي، بافتراض أننا رتبنا
الحالات الكلاسيكية كما فعلنا من قبل،
وهو الترتيب الذي
ترونه هنا.
أخذ القيمة المطلقة
المربعة لهذه المدخلات يعطي ربع للأول، وأيضاً ربع للتالي.
القيمة المطلقة المربعة
للصفر تساوي صفر، لذا هذا المدخل لا
يساهم في المجموع.
وأخيراً، للأخير نحصل على 1/2. لذا المجموع يساوي واحد كما هو مطلوب لكي يكون هذا المتجه
متجه حالة كمومية.
الآن قبل لحظة، استخدمنا ترميز
ket زائد وket ناقص للإشارة إلى متجهي حالة qubit ليسا متجهي أساس قياسي.
وأود العودة
إلى هذه النقطة بإيجاز وشرح كيف يُستخدم ترميز Dirac لمتجهات عشوائية وليس فقط لمتجهات الأساس القياسي.
كما ذكرت سابقاً، يمكننا استخدام أي اسم
نريده داخل bra أو ket للإشارة إلى متجه.
الـ kets هي متجهات عمودية
والـ bras هي متجهات أفقية تماماً كما سبق.
كمثال، الحرف اليوناني
بساي يُستخدم بشكل شائع جداً داخل ket للإشارة إلى متجه عشوائي ما،
وهنا نستخدمه لإعطاء
اسم لمتجه الحالة من قبل الذي ليس
له اسم خاص.
عندما نفعل ذلك، الحرف بساي ليس
بالضرورة له أي معنى بحد ذاته.
هو مجرد اسم لمتجه، وهو داخل ket لمساعدتنا على التوضيح
أنه متجه عمودي.
هذا يمكن أن يكون
مربكاً بعض الشيء أحياناً، وهناك احتمال للغموض إذا كان الحرف بساي يمكن أن يرتبط
بحالة كلاسيكية
لنظام ما مثلاً، لكنه عموماً لا
يسبب أي مشاكل، ولا يتوجب عليكم استخدام
ترميز Dirac هكذا
إذا لم تريدوا ذلك. استخدام حرف صغير مثل
u أو v أو w بدون ket هو أيضاً طريقة جيدة
للدلالة على متجه عمودي
أو بشكل أكثر تحديداً،
متجه حالة كمومية.
اختيار الترميز الذي
تستخدمونه للتعبير عن أنفسكم يعود لكم.
فقط تأكدوا من
أن أولاً، معنى ما تحاولون التعبير عنه واضح للآخرين.
وثانياً، أنكم تفهمون ما
يحاول الآخرون التعبير عنه حتى عندما تكون تفضيلاتهم للترميز مختلفة عن تفضيلاتكم.
هناك قاعدة مهمة جداً لاستخدام ترميز Dirac
للمتجهات العشوائية وهي أنه إذا كان لديكم متجه عمودي
قررتم كتابته
كـ ket بساي مثلاً، أو يمكن أن يكون اسم
مختلف داخل ket، فإن المتجه الأفقي bra بساي
يُفهم على أنه
المرافق المنقول للمتجه ket بساي.
وهنا، هذا مكتوب كمعادلة حيث هذا الخنجر هنا يشير إلى المرافق المنقول.
ما هو تحديداً هو
المتجه الأفقي الذي تحصلون عليه بأولاً نقل المتجه، بمعنى أنكم تقلبون
المتجه على جنبه وتغيرونه من عمود إلى صف
دون تغيير المدخلات فعلياً. وثانياً، أخذ المرافق المركب
لكل من المدخلات.
يمكنكم في الواقع إجراء
هاتين العمليتين، النقل والمرافق
المركب لكل مدخل بأي ترتيب أو هاتان
العمليتان تبديليتان.
لذا للمتجه في هذا المثال، بالنظر إلى أننا قررنا
تسمية هذا المتجه ket بساي، يُفهم أن bra بساي
يعني هذا المتجه هنا
حيث نقلنا المتجه بتحويل ket صفر وket
واحد إلى bra صفر وbra واحد، وأخذنا المرافق
المركب لكل مدخل،
ولهذا واحد زائد
اثنان ضرب i على ثلاثة يتحول إلى واحد ناقص اثنان
ضرب i على ثلاثة هنا.
إليكم كيف تبدو هذه المتجهات عندما تُكتب
صراحة كمتجه عمودي ومتجه أفقي.
لاحظوا بالمناسبة أن
هذه القاعدة متسقة مع الترميز الذي نستخدمه عندما تكون الحالات الكلاسيكية
داخل bra وket.
في تلك الحالة، المدخلات
كلها صفر ما عدا واحد واحد، وبالتالي أخذ المرافق
المركب لا يفعل شيئاً في تلك الحالة.
لقد رأينا الآن كيف تُمثل الحالات الكمومية كمتجهات، لكن ليس واضحاً عند هذه
النقطة ما هو المعنى أو التضمينات
من حيث ما
يمكنكم فعله مع نظام في حالة كمومية أو كيف يمكنكم التفاعل معه.
أول شيء نحتاج فعله لجعل هذه القضايا واضحة
هو مناقشة القياسات.
حدسياً،
القياسات توفر آلية لاستخراج المعلومات
الكلاسيكية من الأنظمة الكمومية.
عندما ننظر إلى نظام
وهو في حالة كمومية، لا نرى حالة كمومية تماماً كما لا نرى
حالات احتمالية،
نرى حالات كلاسيكية، وهذا المفهوم للقياس هو ما يوفر الواجهة.
إذا أردنا نحن كبشر معرفة شيء عن نظام كمومي، علينا قياسه، وبفعل ذلك سنستخرج معلومات كلاسيكية
عن أي حالة كمومية
كان فيها ذلك النظام.
هناك مفاهيم مختلفة
للقياسات. الفرق هو في الواقع فرق في
العمومية، وسنبدأ بالأبسط والأكثر أساسية،
والذي يسمى عادة
قياس الأساس القياسي.
سنعمم هذا
في الدروس اللاحقة. سنتحدث عما يسمى
القياسات الإسقاطية في الدرس الثالث، ولاحقاً في
الوحدة الثالثة من السلسلة،
سنتحدث عن القياسات العامة، والتي تسمى أيضاً مقاييس القيمة
المؤثرة الموجبة أو POVMs اختصاراً.
لكن حالياً، سنقصر اهتمامنا على قياسات الأساس القياسي.
عندما يُجرى قياس
على نظام، ستكون هناك مجموعة
من النتائج الممكنة لذلك القياس، وهي نتائج كلاسيكية،
وفي حالة
قياس الأساس القياسي، تلك النتائج الممكنة هي
بالضبط الحالات الكلاسيكية لأي نظام يُقاس.
كل من تلك الحالات الكلاسيكية ستكون نتيجة القياس باحتمال ما، وذلك الاحتمال هو
القيمة المطلقة المربعة
للمدخل المقابل
لتلك الحالة الكلاسيكية من أي متجه حالة كمومية
كان النظام فيه مباشرة قبل القياس.
نعلم أن القيمة المطلقة المربعة لأي عدد مركب هي عدد حقيقي غير سالب، ونعلم من تعريف
متجهات الحالة الكمومية
أن مجموع القيم
المطلقة المربعة لمدخلات متجه حالة كمومية يساوي واحد.
لذا هذا منطقي. كل حالة كلاسيكية ستظهر كنتيجة
للقياس باحتمال ما والاحتمالات مجموعها واحد.
إليكم بعض الأمثلة. أولاً، لنفترض أن لدينا
qubit في حالة الزائد.
إذا قسنا هذا الـ qubit بالنسبة لقياس
الأساس القياسي، نحصل إما على صفر أو
واحد كنتيجة.
احتمال الحصول على صفر هو القيمة المطلقة
المربعة لواحد على جذر اثنين، وهي 1/2، وهذا نفس
احتمال الحصول على واحد.
لذا إذا قستم حالة الزائد، ستحصلون على بت عشوائي منتظم.
إذا كان النظام في حالة
ناقص بدلاً من حالة زائد، فالقياس يعمل
بنفس الطريقة تماماً.
الاحتمالات مرة أخرى 1/2 لكل نتيجة ممكنة.
الفرق الوحيد هنا هو أن علامة الزائد تحولت إلى علامة ناقص، لكن عندما نأخذ القيمة
المطلقة، لا شيء يتغير.
إذا قسنا حالة الـ qubit هذه، احتمال الحصول على النتيجة صفر هو القيمة المطلقة المربعة لواحد زائد اثنان ضرب i
على ثلاثة، وهي 5/9،
واحتمال الحصول على النتيجة واحد هو القيمة المطلقة المربعة
لسالب 2/3، وهي 4/9.
وأخيراً، قياس
حالة الأساس القياسي ket صفر يعطي النتيجة
صفر بشكل مؤكد، وبالمثل قياس الحالة ket واحد
يعطي النتيجة واحد بشكل مؤكد. وذلك لأن القيمة
المطلقة المربعة للواحد هي واحد.
مشابهاً لما كان لدينا في
الإطار الاحتمالي. يمكننا ربط هاتين الحالتين
الكموميتين ket صفر وket واحد بكون النظام في
تلك الحالات الكلاسيكية،
وهذا المثال يتسق
مع ذلك التفسير.
الآن، تماماً كما كان لدينا في
الإطار الاحتمالي، إذا قسنا نظاماً وهو
في حالة كمومية،
فإن الحالة ستتغير بشكل عام نتيجة لإجراء
ذلك القياس.
على وجه الخصوص، ومرة أخرى هذا مطابق تماماً لما كان
لدينا في الإطار الاحتمالي.
إذا قسنا نظاماً وكانت نتيجة القياس
هي الحالة الكلاسيكية a، فإن الحالة الكمومية
الجديدة للنظام تصبح ket a.
لذا لهذه الحالة
هنا مثلاً، نرى نفس النوع
من السلوك الذي كان لدينا في الإطار الاحتمالي.
إذا قسنا فباحتمال 5/9، نحصل على النتيجة صفر، وفي هذه الحالة الحالة
تنتقل إلى ket صفر،
وباحتمال
4/9، النتيجة هي واحد، والحالة تنتقل إلى ket واحد.
أحياناً يُشار إلى هذه الظاهرة بانهيار
الحالة الكمومية، وهي نوع
الشيء الذي يبقي
من يدرسون أسس
ميكانيكا الكم مستيقظين في الليل.
لكن من منظور
رياضي بحت، هي بسيطة حقاً جداً
ومشابهة جداً لما لدينا في الحالة الاحتمالية.
مصدر التوتر هنا بمعنى ما يتعلق بالطبيعة الأساسية
للحالات الكمومية وما تمثله وكيف تختلف
عن الحالات الاحتمالية. لكن على المستوى الرياضي، هذا ربما ما تتوقعونه.
لاحظوا بالمناسبة أنه إذا
قستم مرة ثانية، ستحصلون على نفس
النتيجة تماماً كما في القياس الأول.
لذا هناك حد لمقدار
المعلومات الكلاسيكية التي يمكن استخراجها من حالة كمومية، وسنعود لهذه النقطة قريباً
في درس آخر. لقد تحدثنا عن الحالات الكمومية وكذلك القياسات، تحديداً قياسات الأساس القياسي،
التي توفر طريقة
لاستخراج المعلومات الكلاسيكية من الحالات الكمومية.
الموضوع المتبقي
في هذا الدرس هو العمليات، تحديداً العمليات الأحادية، التي تصف كيف
يمكن تغيير حالات الأنظمة الكمومية.
بطبيعة الحال، بالنظر إلى أن متجهات
الحالة الكمومية مختلفة عن متجهات الاحتمال، تتوقعون أن مجموعة
العمليات المسموح بها
على الحالات الكمومية مختلفة عما لدينا
للمعلومات الكلاسيكية، وبالفعل هذا هو الحال.
بينما العمليات على الحالات الاحتمالية تُمثل بمصفوفات عشوائية، العمليات على متجهات الحالة الكمومية
تُمثل بمصفوفات أحادية.
إليكم تعريف المصفوفات الأحادية.
مصفوفة مربعة U ذات مدخلات
أعداد مركبة تكون أحادية إذا حققت المتساويات
التي ترونها هنا.
الخنجر يمثل
المرافق المنقول، الذي رأيناه سابقاً للمتجهات عندما تحدثنا عن ترميز
Dirac قبل لحظات.
هنا نجري المرافق
المنقول على مصفوفة بدلاً من متجه، لكنه في الأساس نفس الشيء.
ننقل المصفوفة، مما يعني ببساطة أننا
نتبادل الصفوف والأعمدة، فيصبح المدخل JK هو المدخل KJ،
وأيضاً نأخذ المرافق
المركب لكل مدخل.
أيضاً، هذا الترميز هنا
يعني مصفوفة الهوية.
هاتان المتساويتان
هنا متكافئتان في الواقع. إذا كانت لديكم واحدة،
تحصلون تلقائياً على الأخرى.
كلتاهما مكافئتان للقول
بأن U قابلة للعكس، والعكس يساوي
المرافق المنقول.
هذا صحيح فقط للمصفوفات
المربعة بالمناسبة. إذا كانت لديكم مصفوفة ليست مربعة، فقد تكون إحدى هاتين
المتساويتين صحيحة،
لكن الأخرى لن تكون صحيحة.
لكن هنا، نتحدث
عن مصفوفات مربعة.
لذا هذا هو التعريف
القياسي للمصفوفات الأحادية، وهو جيد لأنه سهل التحقق
مما إذا كانت المصفوفة أحادية.
فقط اضربوا المصفوفة في مرافقها المنقول من أي جهة، وانظروا هل تحصلون على
مصفوفة الهوية.
هناك طريقة مكافئة لتوصيف المصفوفات الأحادية، وهي أن
المصفوفة المربعة أحادية إذا وفقط إذا لم تغير أبداً
المعيار الإقليدي
لأي متجه عند الضرب. مصفوفة N في N تكون U أحادية إذا وفقط إذا كان
المعيار الإقليدي لـ U ضرب v
يساوي المعيار الإقليدي لـ v لكل متجه عمودي v ذي بُعد n ومدخلات أعداد مركبة.
وبالتالي، إذا كان v
متجه حالة كمومية، فإن U ضرب v هو أيضاً
متجه حالة كمومية لأن متجهات الحالة الكمومية
هي ببساطة المتجهات التي
معيارها الإقليدي يساوي واحد.
في الواقع، يمكننا قول المزيد، وهو أن المصفوفات الأحادية هي بالضبط المصفوفات التي تحول دائماً
متجهات الحالة الكمومية
إلى متجهات حالة كمومية. هذا وضع مشابه لما لدينا مع المصفوفات العشوائية
ومتجهات الاحتمال.
المصفوفات العشوائية
هي بالضبط المصفوفات التي تحول دائماً متجهات الاحتمال إلى متجهات احتمال.
لذا بمجرد أن قررنا أن العمليات يجب أن تُمثل بمصفوفات، وهو نفس القول بأن التحويلات تعمل بشكل خطي
على المتجهات التي تمثل الحالات، هذه الاختيارات لمجموعات
العمليات المسموح بها تتبع بشكل طبيعي، على الأقل
بالمعنى الرياضي.
الآن لنلقي نظرة على بعض أمثلة عمليات qubit الأحادية.
سنرى المزيد من الأمثلة
على العمليات الأحادية في الدروس اللاحقة، بما في ذلك عمليات أحادية على أنظمة
لديها أكثر من حالتين كلاسيكيتين. لكن حالياً سنركز فقط
على عمليات qubit الأحادية.
سنرى هذه
الأمثلة بالذات تظهر مراراً وتكراراً، لذا يستحق التعرف على
هذه العمليات بالتأكيد.
المجموعة الأولى من الأمثلة هي ما يسمى عمليات Pauli.
هذه هي العمليات التي تقابل مصفوفات Pauli، المعروضة هنا.
كلها أحادية، ويمكنكم التحقق من ذلك لكل واحدة وفقاً للتعريف من قبل.
هذه المصفوفات بالذات
تصادف أنها مساوية لمرافقاتها المنقولة، أي أنها
كلها مصفوفات هرميتية.
لذا التحقق من أنها
كلها أحادية، في هذه الحالة، هو مسألة تربيع كل واحدة ورؤية أن النتيجة
هي مصفوفة الهوية.
الأسماء التي ترونها لهذه
المصفوفات قياسية جداً، وسترون أيضاً سيغما
x وسيغما y وسيغما z تسمى ببساطة X وY وZ.
لكن كونوا على علم بأن
الأحرف الكبيرة X وY وZ تُستخدم أيضاً بشكل شائع لأغراض أخرى، حتى في سياق
المعلومات الكمومية،
لكنها أسماء شائعة
جداً لهذه المصفوفات.
عملية سيغما x أو X
تسمى أيضاً قلب البت أو عملية النفي، التي رأيناها سابقاً
في السياق الكلاسيكي.
وعملية سيغما z أو Z
تسمى أيضاً قلب الطور.
وهنا يمكنكم رؤية
تأثير هذه العمليات على متجهات الأساس القياسي، مما يوضح نوعاً ما
من أين جاءت هذه الأسماء.
بالتأكيد، من المنطقي
الإشارة إلى سيغما x كقلب للبت بناءً على هذا التأثير هنا.
إنها ببساطة تقلب البت من
صفر إلى واحد أو من واحد إلى صفر.
ومن المنطقي أيضاً
تسمية سيغما z بقلب الطور بناءً على هذا التأثير هنا.
لكن إذا لم يكن ذلك واضحاً تماماً
في الوقت الحالي، لا بأس.
سنصادف هذه
العملية مراراً وتكراراً وأهمية
وضع علامة سالب أمام متجه الأساس ket واحد
وليس ket صفر
ولماذا يسمى ذلك قلب الطور ستكون أوضح لاحقاً.
المثال التالي هو
عملية Hadamard، المُمثلة
بهذه المصفوفة هنا، والتي تُسمى دائماً تقريباً H.
التحقق من أن H أحادية هو مرة أخرى
حساب مباشر، والذي إذا ابتعدت عن الطريق، يمكنكم رؤيته هنا.
مشابهاً لمصفوفات Pauli، H هي مرافقها المنقول.
لذا لدينا هذه المتساوية هنا، وعندما نجري الضرب، نحصل على مصفوفة الهوية كما هو مطلوب.
المثال الثالث هو
في الحقيقة فئة كاملة من العمليات الأحادية
تُعرف بعمليات الطور.
هذه عمليات
مُمثلة بأي مصفوفة تأخذ هذا الشكل
الذي ترونه هنا حيث ثيتا هو أي عدد حقيقي.
لذا هذا المدخل هنا سيكون
دائماً عدداً مركباً على دائرة الوحدة.
مصفوفات كهذه هي دائماً أحادية، وهو ما سأتركه لكم للتحقق.
هذه المرة، المرافق المنقول لن يساوي المصفوفة الأصلية ما لم يكن هذا العدد هنا يصادف
أنه واحد أو سالب واحد،
وفي هذه الحالة ننتهي بإما
مصفوفة الهوية أو سيغما z، اللتين
صادفناهما سابقاً.
تحديداً، النقل
لن يفعل شيئاً لهذه المصفوفة، لكن أخذ المرافق
المركب لكل مدخل يغير هذا المدخل هنا
إلى e أس سالب i ثيتا.
هاتان العمليتان بالذات هنا هما أمثلة مهمة بشكل خاص
لعمليات الطور.
للأولى، نأخذ
ثيتا لتكون باي على اثنين، ونحصل على هذه المصفوفة هنا.
هذه تُسمى عادة عملية
S أو S gate عندما نتحدث عن circuits، وهو ما لن نناقشه في هذا الدرس،
لكنه موضوع مهم
قادم قريباً.
الثانية هي هذه العملية. إنها عملية T أو T gate.
ولهذه، ثيتا
تساوي باي على أربعة. وعندما نحسب الأسية، نحصل على هذه القيمة هنا، وهي واحد زائد i على
الجذر التربيعي لاثنين.
إليكم بعض الأمثلة السريعة لرؤية بعض هذه
العمليات أثناء العمل.
إليكم تأثير
عملية Hadamard على ket صفر وket واحد.
إذا أجرينا
ضرب المصفوفة في المتجه، نرى أن ما نحصل عليه هو حالة الزائد وحالة
الناقص على التوالي.
إذا أجرينا عملية Hadamard على حالة الزائد
وحالة الناقص، من ناحية أخرى، نعود إلى ket صفر وket واحد.
لذا إذا رتبنا الأمور قليلاً، يمكننا رؤية التأثير بشكل أوضح.
عملية Hadamard
تحول ذهاباً وإياباً بين حالة الصفر وحالة الزائد وبين حالة الواحد
وحالة الناقص.
بخصوص هاتين المعادلتين هنا، لاحظوا أن هذا يعطينا طريقة بسيطة للكشف عن الفرق بين حالة الزائد وحالة الناقص.
كما رأينا سابقاً في الدرس، إذا قسنا حالة
الزائد وحالة الناقص بالنسبة لقياس
الأساس القياسي،
نحصل على بت عشوائي منتظم في كلتا الحالتين، مما لا يساعدنا على
كشف الفرق.
لكن إذا أجرينا عملية
Hadamard ثم قسنا، سنرى صفر إذا كانت
الحالة الأصلية حالة زائد
وواحد إذا كانت الحالة
الأصلية حالة ناقص.
لذا هاتان الحالتان مختلفتان فعلاً، ويمكن التمييز
بينهما بشكل كامل بالطريقة التي وصفتها للتو،
وهي أولاً إجراء
عملية Hadamard ثم القياس.
بالعودة إلى مثال
حالة qubit التي رأيناها سابقاً والتي ليست خاصة بشكل معين، يمكننا رؤية ما تفعله عملية Hadamard
لهذه الحالة
بالتحويل إلى الأشكال
التي ترونها هنا وإجراء الضرب.
وإليكم النتيجة
التي يمكننا تحويلها مرة أخرى إلى ترميز Dirac إذا أردنا،
وهذه طريقة لحساب
هذه الأنواع من التأثيرات.
إليكم مثالاً آخر يوضح أنكم لا تحتاجون دائماً
للتحويل صراحة إلى شكل المصفوفة والمتجه.
يمكنكم أيضاً إجراء هذه
الحسابات مباشرة باستخدام ترميز Dirac.
هذا المثال يتعلق بعملية T، وإليكم هي
هنا كمرجع فقط.
هذه العملية لها هذا التأثير هنا على حالات الأساس القياسي.
وإذا أردنا حساب
تأثير عملية T على حالة الزائد مثلاً، يمكننا البدء بتوسيع
تعريف حالة الزائد
ثم استخدام الخطية
للتعبير عن النتيجة كما ترون هنا.
يمكننا الآن ببساطة تعويض
هذه التعابير في الأعلى، وإجراء القليل من
التبسيط للحد الثاني، والحصول على النتيجة.
إذا أردنا لأي سبب تطبيق عملية Hadamard
على النتيجة، يمكننا فعل شيء مشابه.
أولاً، نعوض التعبير عن T مطبقة على حالة الزائد ونستخدم الخطية كما فعلنا من قبل.
والآن، إذا عوضنا
التعابير التي لدينا سابقاً لعملية Hadamard
مطبقة على ket صفر وket واحد،
نحصل على هذا. والآن يمكننا توسيع
حالة الزائد وحالة الناقص للحصول على هذا التعبير هنا،
الذي يمكننا تبسيطه بالجمع فقط، وإليكم النتيجة النهائية.
لا يوجد شيء خاص بشكل
معين في هذا المثال. هو مجرد توضيح
لهذه الطريقة البديلة لكن المكافئة
لحساب تأثيرات
هذه العمليات. يمكنكم استخدام أي
طريقة أكثر ملاءمة في الوضع الذي بين أيديكم.
نقطة أخيرة حول
العمليات الأحادية هي أن تركيبات العمليات
الأحادية تُمثل بضرب المصفوفات
تماماً كما في الإطار الاحتمالي، أي يمكنكم حساب تأثير سلسلة من العمليات الأحادية
بضرب
المصفوفات معاً ببساطة. وما ستحصلون عليه هو
مصفوفة أحادية واحدة تمثل التأثير المشترك
لسلسلة العمليات.
تماماً كما كان لدينا مع المصفوفات العشوائية، المصفوفات الأحادية
مغلقة تحت الضرب، لذا ستحصلون دائماً على مصفوفة أحادية
عندما تركبون عمليات أحادية.
يجب أن تتأكدوا من
ضرب المصفوفات بالترتيب الصحيح.
لكن الطريقة التي يعمل بها الأمر هي تماماً كما كانت مع
العمليات العشوائية حيث مصفوفة العملية الأولى
التي تجرونها
ستظهر دائماً على الجانب الأيمن
من جداء المصفوفات، والأخيرة ستظهر
على الجانب الأيسر.
لذا تماماً كما سبق، الترتيب معكوس بمعنى أنكم تركبون من اليمين إلى اليسار بدلاً من اليسار إلى اليمين.
إليكم مثالاً مثيراً يؤدي إلى عملية تُعرف بعملية الجذر التربيعي للنفي.
لنفترض أننا أولاً
نطبق عملية Hadamard تليها عملية S، تليها عملية Hadamard أخرى.
التأثير المشترك لهذه
العمليات الثلاث يوصف بهذا الجداء.
إليكم عملية Hadamard الأولى، إليكم عملية S، وإليكم عملية Hadamard الثانية.
إذا أجرينا ضرب المصفوفات، وهو غير معروض هنا صراحة، لكن يمكنكم فعل ذلك
بأنفسكم إذا أردتم،
النتيجة هي هذه المصفوفة هنا. إنها مصفوفة أحادية، ويمكننا إما التحقق من ذلك مباشرة
أو يمكننا الوثوق بحقيقة أن المصفوفات الأحادية
مغلقة تحت الضرب.
يجب أن تكون أحادية لأن هذه المصفوفات الثلاث أحادية كما رأينا سابقاً.
ليس لدينا متجه حالة
كمومية محدد في الاعتبار هنا.
يمكننا تخيل إجراء
هذه السلسلة من العمليات على أي متجه حالة كمومية، وهذه المصفوفة تصف التأثير.
السبب في تسمية هذه العملية المركبة، أي تلك الموصوفة
بهذه المصفوفة هنا، بعملية الجذر التربيعي للنفي،
هو أنه بإجرائها
مرتين، نحصل على عملية نفي، أو بعبارة أخرى، عملية
سيغما x أو عملية X.
إجراء العملية
مرتين يُمثل بتربيع المصفوفة أو
ضربها في نفسها.
وإذا فعلتم ذلك، سترون أن النتيجة
هي مصفوفة Pauli x.
وهذا غريب نوعاً ما، ويعطيكم مجرد لمحة عن أنه يمكنكم فعل بعض الأشياء المثيرة مع المعلومات الكمومية لا يمكنكم فعلها مع
المعلومات الكلاسيكية.
لا توجد عملية كلاسيكية، أي عملية مُمثلة
بمصفوفة عشوائية، تعطينا عملية نفي
إذا أجريناها مرتين.
لذا هو مثال جميل يكشف أن العمليات الكمومية
تتصرف بشكل مختلف جداً عن العمليات الكلاسيكية.
وهذا كل شيء للدرس الأول. في هذا الدرس، ناقشنا كيف تعمل المعلومات الكمومية للأنظمة المفردة في عزلة،
وفي الدرس القادم، سنتحدث عن كيف
تعمل المعلومات الكمومية لأنظمة متعددة.
شكراً للمشاهدة. إذا كان لديكم أي أسئلة، لا تترددوا في تركها في
قسم التعليقات أدناه.